what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have a lot
of awesome exciting things to talk about
we have a little bit of information
about loki season two which is about to
start filming and this information is
coming from michael waldron the writer
of season 1 and the writer of multiverse
of madness looks like we have some
pretty good news for those defender fans
out there as it looks like we could be
seeing them appear in the mcu at
different points in time we have some
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and
guardians of the galaxy holiday special
news to go over and to top it all off it
looks like hawkeye could be getting a
season two and some changes that moon
knight made before have seemingly been
undone so a lot of really exciting news
to talk about today and by the way if
you missed my video yesterday disney
plus day has been announced for
september 8th and that is also when
disney's d23 begins it is from september
8th to september 10th so expect a lot of
big news about the mcu about star wars
and just disney in general those few
days and of course i'll be covering that
and everything until then and after then
so be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos so
let's start with loki season 2 because a
lot of fans are really looking forward
to loki season 2 including myself they
left us on a pretty massive cliffhanger
at the end of loki season 1 and they
left us asking what the heck is going on
loki after forming a very deep and a
very real relationship with mobius and
sylvie was kind of abandoned by sylvie
and went back to a tva that was
completely different and to a mobius who
did not know who he was now something
that is very very important that you
have to know about loki's season 1
multiverse of madness and loki 2 is that
marvel studios president kevin feige
said that everything that happened in
spider-man no way home and in multiverse
of madness was only possible because of
what happened at the end of loki loki
and sylvie took down the tva and they
took out he who remains and the only
reason any of this could have happened
in the mcu is because of those events
otherwise he who remains in the tva
would have stepped in and prevented
multiverse of madness and spider-man no
way home they would have stopped doctor
strange from doing all these things so
essentially you can blame spider-man
knowing home and the events of
multiverse of madness on loki and sylvie
or you can thank them because those
movies were awesome but it looks like
loki season 2 is actually going to be
somewhat of a continuation of these
events so and somewhat it's kind of
going to be the follow-up of multiverse
of madness basically a lot is going to
happen between the events of loki season
1 and the events of loki season 2 but
the tva kind of exists outside of space
and time so we'll have to see how that
actually affects it but spider-man
knowing home doctor strange two and then
ant-man and the wasp quantum mania where
the true king the conqueror will be
revealed would have all come out before
loki season two season two for loki is
about to start filming and we have a ton
of disney plus projects coming out this
year so we know it's not coming out this
year it's probably going to be coming
out mid 2023 and february of 2023 is
when ant-man and the wasp guantamania
come out so expect a lot to be going on
in loki season 2 and it's going to be
really really important but according to
the writer of season 1 and multiverse of
madness michael waldron has kind of
teased us that we might see how the tva
approaches these events that have taken
place in the mcu after the previous tva
that we knew in season 1 has fallen and
now kang's new tva is in charge in a
recent interview he was asked about the
events of season 2 of loki and he said
it remains to be seen how did the events
of this movie play out through the lens
of the tva and he was speaking of
multiverse madness he says what would
they look like on a chrono monitor i
don't know we'll have to find out so it
looks like loki season 2 is going to be
tackling a lot of different things of
course we'll have to explore sylvia
again mobius the tva kang will be
officially in the mcu at this point in
time and the multiverse is kind of a
mess incursions are happening so this is
going to be really important and really
really exciting and speaking of second
seasons it looks like hawkeye might be
getting a season two i know there's a
lot of hawkeye fans out there a lot of
kate bishop fans out there so this is
good news now the reason we think this
is because on the emmys for your
consideration page for disney hawkeye
used to say limited series but now it
has been changed to outstanding comedy
series so that could be because it has
been green lit for a season two and
hopefully if this does happen this will
be the start of the new avengers team
and hopefully the young avengers team as
well it's about time we get some
avengers back in the mcu now at the same
time right now a season two for moon
night is kind of up in the air
originally on their twitter page it said
marvel studios is moon knight a limited
series now streaming only on disney plus
now however it says an original series
now streaming only on disney plus not
limited however on the four-year
consideration emmy page it still does
say limited series it actually says
limited or anthology series now i
personally would love a moon knight
series over a hawkeye series nothing
against hawkeye and i do love kate
bishop but i would like more new things
to come into the mcu rather than doing
some sequels that might not have such a
huge impact on the mcu hawkeye was great
but i really welcome new characters now
speaking of new characters but also kind
of old characters it looks like the
defenders might actually be making mcu
appearances after all we've already seen
daredevil well we've seen charlie cox
but we did see kingpin and now a
daredevil series is coming to disney
plus in the future and not to mention
daredevil will be in the echo series as
well but according to a new report from
screen geek they have been told by a
source that kristen ritter aka jessica
jones is going to be appearing in an mcu
project soon now after seeing matt
murdock show up in spider-man no way
home after seeing kingpin show up in the
hawkeye series and then blackbolt
showing up in multiverse of madness
although he's an inhuman of course not a
defender but the main point is that
marvel studios seems to be taking these
characters that used to be on the
netflix series and has zero problem with
weaving them into the mcu so right now
it is literally possible that any of the
defenders any of the old inhumans any
people from agents of shield it's
entirely possible that they could appear
in the mcu the multiverse has shown us
that anything is now possible in the
grand scale of the marvel cinematic
universe and if this report is accurate
it looks like we will be seeing jessica
jones soon now to top it all off we have
some guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and
guardians of galaxy holiday special news
it has been confirmed that daniella
melquire has joined the cast of
guardians of the galaxy vol 3. this was
reported by deadline but confirmed by
james gunn you gotta love that about
james gunn when reports happen and break
on the internet he's always there to
either debunk them or confirm if they're
true so james gunn said on twitter i can
confirm and confirm she's wonderful in
the role daniela mcguire is one of my
favorite people and actors around and i
hope this is just the second of many
projects we'll work on together now the
deadline report did not mention what
role she was playing and james gunn did
not confirm that role either but it is
said to be a small role and not a
massive role now if you watched the
suicide squad from james gunn you know
that she was in this movie as ratcatcher
and she did an amazing job so i'm
excited to see her in guardians 3. now
guardians 3 and the holiday special have
finished filming they've wrapped and
they sent out rap gifts the gifts that
they give to the cast and crew once
something is done filming this was
shared by mark mantastic on tick-tock we
have a couple of hats one is of rocket
raccoon and the other one seems to be of
groot but this could be a different
character this is from the holiday
special and it looks like it's some type
of a christmas tree with the character
in front of it but the last time that we
saw groot he was a teenager and in the
thor love and thunder trailer he is
still a teenager and this looks like a
full adult groot the groot that we saw
in the first guardians of the galaxy
film so this could be group or this
could be the high evolutionary or a
character that the high evolutionary
could have created with his experiments
but then we take a look at the top right
we have a new logo for the guardians of
the galaxy you can see the old logo is
on the bottom for comparison and it
looks like the logo is simply stepping
away from the guardian's name on it now
it's speculated that this could mean
that the guardians are becoming more of
an official team we do know that this is
pretty much the last film of this
guardian's team we're expecting a few
deaths to happen in guardians 3. james
gunn and a few members of the cast have
mentioned that this is it for them
they're done after this so perhaps the
guardians become a real guardians of the
galaxy team where members can actually
join and leave at any point in time that
way the members can leave but the
guardian's team always remains a knack
they're always going to be the guardians
of the galaxy but characters like nova
or adam warlock or the silver surfer can
always join which is really exciting and
like i said a lot of news that's
happened over the past week let me know
what your favorite part of all of this
is in the comments down below and what
you're most excited for don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you